foreign
[Music]
welcome to to title Tuesday
um it's gonna be a fun one
okay Swifty polish FM
okay it's currently disconnected
okay you gave you spotted me a minute
he spotted me a minute
he says sorry Uber Eats
whoa okay
I mean he doesn't have to apologize
yeah I guess I don't have to rush
yeah this line
I think I can get away okay it doesn't
could go E4
foreign
if Knight D2 I want to go E3 essentially
on Knight G4
yeah maybe he had a second delivery
all right hello
yeah I mean I hope he's enjoying his
food because he's got 30 more seconds
let's go H5 I mean I'm making all the
normals I'm not really okay but yeah
this
wait here I have to be careful actually
here I actually have to be careful
yeah I walked into this
that's not good
I forgot he has Knight D5 it's your
queen E7
going through
oh he takes it he goes into the bishop
ah he's got this one this one I missed
and now it's actually probably worse for
me
okay wait let's go repeat it
wow
Progressive defense
what I can take now
hmm
yeah I think you just take
yeah I kind of needed that I needed that
extra time
that was some pretty impressive play by
him in time scramble but eventually I
just
tricked him
from Azerbaijan dangerous
always dangerous this is area FM's
okay let's play my main line which is
Knight D2
people mostly go C5 now
okay it takes
what is the Fort Knox
which I don't know too well I mean I
know that
castles I know Ray Robinson taught me
this
yeah
I'm not sure what to take back with
I guess I'll take with the Knight Maybe
let's go C4
yeah this is always annoying this is
always annoying this move
because I never know whether to go A4 or
A3
I'm gonna go A3 I'm going to try to
minimize the weaknesses
C5
and we're gonna go in C2 or queen E2 or
to the side though let's see
some picks
let's go Bishop B2 and I have the nice
B5 Square for the night
yeah white is definitely better but I
don't know if it's gonna be enough
okay it was there I kind of want to play
H3 crates or maybe even G3 but
I don't really need to make looks just
yet I can maybe play
Bishop D4
it's gonna harass him a little bit
the ghost Queen A6 I'll go G3
should I go B4
this feels wrong to go before but I'll
do it
okay at least I got him to think
okay 97 I'm gonna go Queen B3 to find
the pawn
kind of mistake for it
this one I did see I thought
yeah he finds a nice move
that one I missed
yeah that's actually
super super impressive resource
going to be tough to win now
shouldn't have gone before I should have
it's quite amazing that there's really
no good moves here let's take and go C5
at least
and I shouldn't be worse here
I definitely shouldn't be worse
nobody has this move wait but I have
maybe this move
can I not trap his Knight
ah he's got Rook at eight
okay let's give it a shot this feels
right
yes I have one title Tuesday before
I mean pretty bad is an understatement
but the question is can he save the
night
this is the nitrogate bishop D1
I don't see how he probably holds
tonight
okay I'm just gonna play Bishop D1
instantly to keep the foot on the gas
pedal in terms of his clock I think he's
gonna go Knight F4
it was nice to see three way now that
does not help I mean he loses the
exchange
wait let's see if I can let me think
about this for a hot second
there's several ways that I can go about
winning the exchange I think the way
that I'm gonna do it is I'm going to
take care first
and I'm gonna take here
and I'm gonna win with this
yeah this is over
this one's over
I mean I can probably just go for ships
GG
okay next game we're playing predki the
guy who just beat Liam
okay what's going for him this guy's
good he's like 26 80 feet
let's play Lopez
okay 97.
[Music]
actually wait what do I want to do let's
go Knight C3
okay G6
24.
and go like this I know this is good for
white but I don't remember any actual
details
yeah he's gonna put us to go H6
this way it goes B5
so I have Knight takes D4
or am I crazy
I'm probably crazy but whatever
yeah but unfortunately I was hoping for
a trap which using this Bowl before
I'm not really sure why I did what I
just did
I have Knight F6
Bishop F6
but obviously this just gives me an
advantage I mean the question is what
kind of advantage
yeah but sadly I missed castles yeah
yeah
this is gonna be
winnable position but tough to win
there's a bunch of double Pawns
but unfortunately it's Obstacle of
Bishop so it's going to be tough
yeah okay
[Music]
foreign
probably should have gotten
yeah I should have maybe got considered
G4 and H5 just going for mate
yeah definitely should have considered
you for an H5
[Music]
yeah yeah that was a fundamentally wrong
plan I think by me
okay still obviously a good position
but this is going to be very hard to win
okay Rook d8 because it would be in
there
all right let's bring the king up
I mean he has some F5 nonsense but
actually maybe the time has arrived for
us to bring it back to F6 so that we
avoid F5 related
okay I don't know I don't think he has a
discovery of any kind
okay she's gonna go back and forth I
think what I'm going to try to do is go
G4
and I don't see a reason to
procrastinate I'm just gonna play it now
C4
he wants her to be five but then I have
E5
so which Rook do we want
where
I really don't know
I don't know what to do here I think
okay let's make a move
okay I'm gonna try to play for mate here
oh I plundered the pun
yeah I've loaded the pawn yeah
let's go here
still gonna go for me it doesn't change
anything
ah but he's got this move now
man somehow he's
getting out of it
yeah
I messed this one up
he's got forever to think about this
um it's a good move
oh man I'm trying to lose this
I'm trying really hard to lose this
I think I succeeded
mm-hmm
I'm gonna win this though
it's not easy
[Music]
yeah it's winning I failed to lose it
that was a nice comeback once I blended
the pawn
yeah and I let his rook in but this
exchange stack was a kind of money
decision I think because I realized the
bishop is a really strong here
and it's hard for him to get to my king
so it was a good practical decision even
if
objectively now it's like a three years
old game
yeah it's important not to panic when
you've got a lot of time just to make
the best move you can make
of course you're going to make tons of
mistakes and stuff but
it's just part of the part of the part
of the fun
yeah Rook C4 is correct it's the only
move actually to keep the balance
computer theater gives equality
you're welcome
glad you did
instead of E5 G5
oh it's made yeah G5 is made
I should have seen that G5 and H5 yeah I
forgot that I could cut them off that
way
yeah
I mean it's it's
very easy in retrospect
yeah I don't know why that didn't occur
to me
fatigue yeah E5 gives him
this and still G5 is winning I just
missed this idea G5 H5
I only considered H5 and then he has G5
and he keeps this game live I forgot
that I could push the pawn to G5 first
and then
and then H5 and
yeah
it's fine
all right solid game four out of four
um
all right next game
playing Mr kolars
okay it goes Knight F3 all right
he's probably deciding between
foreign
but I don't remember much
okay Queen D2
so if memory serves me right the move
here is D5 94 takes
day one Knight D6
the one I don't really like
I think it's fair to say that G5 is
okay Knight H4 interesting plane
so if I go 94 a 94 I'm Bishop before
slight Edge for black there
right now I can also go D4 or even DC
[Music]
yeah but D4 it goes Knight F5 that's not
an option so maybe bishop B6
images of Bishop E6
[Music]
and it looks reasonable enough
[Music]
[Music]
there should be one that I guess
step something up his sleeve
[Music]
it might be six obviously I won't take
the queen I'll play a B
to stop an exchange here this should be
a win
okay maybe Queen takes b6s I should have
dedicated some more time to it but
I definitely probably should have
thought about it but okay whatever
let's go here
's Bishop F4 I want Bishop B5
Queen E7 was probably quite a bit
stronger
but okay this is fine
foreign
[Music]
it's actually not so easy to actually
bring them down
don't love what I'm doing here
at all
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh she's good
okay yeah I dropped the ball here
yeah I dropped the ball on this one oh
and I might lose
Juan is the wrong color
foreign
foreign
oh I could have taken that
in here I'm fine
I could have taken that one but who
cares
there's nothing you can do
yeah that's kind of sad
I was Dev completely winning I mean I
was I was up and exchange it I just
couldn't find I mean it's a typical
problem that I have I just can't quite
find the finishing touch it was never
like that winning it's just up a
full exchange for no comp but
I think he defended accurately gotta
give him some credit
he found lots of really good moves of
course I was I'm sure I was completely
winning somewhere here
oh we had rookie seven winning on the
spot though
which he missed
yeah King
yeah no I mean
I don't think there were any specific
mistakes I made
um
it was just overall lots of inaccuracies
probably Bishop D4 here as I had
intended to play
but then decided in the last second to
play BC
yeah
C4 was correct I mean this was all good
B5 is all the top moves
I really made one major mistake which
was to
to go for this end game and then it
wasn't easy
F5 is correct okay whatever we're
playing Ibarra he's got five out of five
so we should try to win this
okay this line that's what I play okay
wait let's play with granddelius fight
against me
what did grendelius play against me I
think he played
this would be three
and then he played
P5 and queen D2
I mean I assume yeah
yeah that's what I also played
I think you're supposed to Castle now
and I headphones keep turning off
foreign
this looks very suspicious thing I think
white is winning here
I don't trust them at all
fun position
okay I'm just gonna play Knight P5 I had
Queen G7 there but I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna think about it I'm
gonna save some time for for a rainy day
who's gonna arrive soon I think
27 okay great
yeah but he's getting away a little bit
he wants to capture
he's kind of getting away by one tempo
which is annoying
okay I have an idea
this feels right to me I don't know why
but Knight ft4 feels right
okay yeah I was worried about that move
you got Knight C6
foreign
G7 which should be winning
okay we can Primo baby
attachment h3's got
your queen F5
okay why don't we take first one
okay I'm winning with either C7 or Rook
p7
foreign
now with discoveries I've got this
language
okay I'm up with a thousand pieces
yeah it was a bad opening I mean I
actually know how to play against this
now because I played this with black and
aim chess
I was playing this with black name just
this idea of just going early Bishop H6
is very dangerous and if once black once
he took I knew this was bad
maybe I didn't play accurately yeah
looks like I didn't play accurately
A6 and black was fine
Knight C6 is the top move though because
I'm happy with that this is good
intuitive assessment by me thank you big
beast
yeah on Rook up seven is also good yeah
very nice and Quinn H3 I spotted this
retreating idea
I spotted it already here
but it it occurred to me that after
Queen HD it's been F5 so I thought maybe
I'll take first to cover the F5 square
and then Queen H3
yeah that was a nice game
that was a nice game
I think this was all crap
yeah whatever
good stuff okay so we have five and a
half out of six we're gonna play
somebody good clearly the musics both
seem to be in very off form okay we're
playing chababa and he's got six out of
six so let's focus
foreign
Knight A6
I play jababa-esque System
thank you a little high there
so this is just a position
let's go A5
and then we're gonna castle and play D5
you can also play D6
I can also play D6 but there should be
slightly worse I'm probably slightly
worse after D5 as well
I don't like this but
but okay I have to play principles
and then F6 Bishop P6 I guess
foreign
[Music]
okay let's try to maybe attack the B3
Pawn I can also put a rook on d8
for starters I think
this should probably not hurt
okay now
yeah
although I ran into deep and I just
walked into the floor
really not the end of the world though I
just take it and won't chill
we're still chilling here okay it
doesn't play it
okay my idea was to tuck the night away
here
put some pressure on B3
and then maybe double Rooks I don't know
it seems a little artificial in the
queen G6
Queen G6 just kind of move she's poking
and prodding a little bit
although I don't know I allowed 94. that
was
myopic of me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
he has B5 but then I thought I maybe
have Knight before
that's 94 whoa it gives me the pawn
really I guess he has some sort of
Knight C5 related shenanigans
uh-huh I think I understand what he
wants
but I don't buy it I'm just I mean I
really don't have a choice I have to say
if Queen V2 I think I have Queenie stuff
otherwise I'm worse
but I think this is an important move
thank you Mark you
I don't buy what he's selling here
okay goes H3
5
I don't even think about taking the pawn
that that's too messy
too complicated
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
yeah
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow he didn't miss the stalemate oh he
flagged oh my God
I'm so sorry
it's such a good trick though look at
that trick I came up with the end this
is a draw
can you believe this trick
[Music]
yeah
I can't believe this game
that was an insane stale Matrix all he
had to do to win
was just take on D7 here and that's it
and finish
yeah he was I mean I
the way he time scrambles is honestly
just
I I don't understand how he does it like
it I think it would take me 30 minutes
to find everything he found in one
millisecond
the guy's understanding is just out of
this world
[Music]
okay so we went
so after the next round there will be a
break we're gonna play Jose
for first place let's try to beat him
let's try to beat him
let's go E4
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I have to be careful because he's got
this D5 trick but I don't remember where
it is I think it's after F3
it is
[Music]
that was a bad move
it's pretty bad
okay let's go here
[Music]
I want to play B3
there should be two if I can get all
these moves then I'll be better but
three he's got this B5 nonsense
okay I have to play these things
but P5 Knight takes B5
6
[Music]
maybe Knight D5
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah sorry didn't create any chances but
here black is just very comfortable
rookie 8 B5 I mean
here I can sense that already if anybody
has to be careful it's probably white
yeah a good play by him in the opening I
just didn't didn't create any chances
and I'm low on time so it's a reasonable
result let's try to go three out of
three in the last three rounds
and then we'll get 10 out of 11. easy as
that
can you show us the statement of jibava
game yeah sure I need a line against D6
that's not Bishop E5 check because this
is
this is just way too flat I mean I won a
lot of games here but
so the stalemate in this game so some I
completely outplayed them
but then somehow in time pressure I just
couldn't figure out the move here
Bishop D5 ah Super Pair of three uh-huh
this is good but Knight E5 is a panic
move
95 is a and then of course there was no
need to get a worse position your Bishop
D7 still winning for black
but I was already intent on panicking
so he was winning like a thousand times
here
I mean here 94 is winning in Rook takes
B7
the bador was also pretty panicky
and here yeah Knight F6 king of fate and
suddenly he realized that after
Rogue D7 Rook F3 it's a draw
that's just a renegade Rook wherever he
goes I just follow him
you Playboy okay there we go we're
playing Bogdan
we're playing bogd and he's a good
players 2700 feet eh all right here we
go
okay it goes for this quiet E3 line yeah
this has been popular recently
okay before so this is a reversed
let's go let's go here
[Music]
very interesting
so I could take on D4
this is let's move a shot actually
fc501 C6 and 94 this looks pretty
appetizing to be honest
also c594 Knight 65 Knight dc5
but that looks too speculative
okay Bishop G5 so he doesn't yeah
probably the correct decision
[Music]
okay when I need to think
okay let's check
this must be okay for me at least okay
a lot better
I don't know about age six but
force them to decide probably I should
have played this move earlier
yeah for sure because now I gave him
facts
all about this but I don't see an
alternative
I mean positionally I'm looking really
good but tactically on the king side I
don't love my position
it's a lot of holes
yep
tomorrow
I know
I want to play A6 so that I can play C6
later and support the Knight but this is
all taking a lot of time
I like my position I think I'm doing
okay
foreign
Knight F6
he's also under now down to a minute
okay 95 played
Knight F6 second F7 wait oh that might
actually be
problematic
no he can't second if somebody can't
freaking B3 at the end
but then I go Queen E7
and he goes work B1
thank you yeah that but otherwise I'm
worse
so let's try it anyway I don't know this
is a speculative move but I'm going to
give it a shot
I want to trade the Bishops off to leave
him with a bad Bishop the bad dark sweet
Bishop
yeah now he's down to 30 seconds so I
got at least some time off his clock
but he's very strong when he's got like
a couple seconds left
yeah this is precisely what I was afraid
of
this is precisely what I was worried
about
I blundered a small tactic
maybe Queen B6
I don't know
it's gonna be six I hope this is not a
blunder
if Queen C4 I'll play Knight D5 I think
it takes it goes Rook would be one
probably going to make it
and there's not much I can do here I can
play rookie seven
and play for the advantage
but I don't know
but I I can't draw I mean if I draw this
game the problem is I just my chance to
win the tournament kind of go out the
window so
we might as well give it a shot
and give it the old College try shall we
[Music]
oh and I think I failed
let's not lose it drives better than a
loss
yeah I missed Knight A5 that's a nice
move
okay I guess I take
yeah
I can take and go C5
the rookie one C5
1
2
I don't know
foreign
I'm gonna torture him
it's just not blowing in my room
can torture him how are we gonna torture
him we're gonna go
just make some moves
a very accurate move very well played
okay H5 let's try
let's not lose on time
let's not lose on time
very accurate defense
foreign
foreign
petition but the problem is I can't do
anything because if I go King F4 he just
goes for cup five this is just a
well-known draw
should have maybe tried something else
but I don't know what there's just
nothing here
I mean I tried my best there's he
definitely well I think probably I
chickened out
I chickened out I knew this was probably
gonna lead to a drop
yeah I'm definitely much better oh no
I'm actually not much better oh it's
just equal
no this is just equal according to the
engine
that was never much better I mean 0.6
with 94 but it just goes here
yeah I never really had anything
sizable
because it's just always zeros
yeah at some point you just I mean these
guys are so solid that if they don't
really want to lose
it's hard to beat them on demand I think
I've played a really nice game overall I
drew from a position of strength that's
all one can ask for against the 2700
feet a player
and I don't think I missed anything here
were no hanging Rooks
yeah the engine is just saying it's fine
but okay
I mean I wouldn't really call him a
project Prodigy anymore he's
okay so farouja I'm gonna play Far Asia
and I need to beat him that's like the
reality because he's got eight out of
nine
we have to be for Russia he's probably
gonna be fine on the draw so I
I can definitely press him I think
he's gonna play Berlin I'm not gonna
make a draw
foreign
let's just play something casual
foreign
[Music]
I hit the Berlin
foreign
I'm really not playing this well
unfortunately
that H4 is a nice move though I think
this generates some chances
I want to go Knight F5
walks into it with Tempo interesting
but he wants this yeah that makes sense
I've got a little something in here
psycho
yeah but again I mean I have an identify
but that's really about it
and this position is going to be
virtually impossible to win against
version
but I'm gonna try let's give our K1
gotta poke and prod a little bit
if you did lose a game in this title
Tuesday so he is beatable
he's totally beautiful
takes it interesting I could actually
take with a pawn potentially it's a
risky move but it's interesting
but probably bad in the end of the day
I don't know which way
maybe G4 but that really weakens the
squares I don't like that
[Music]
thank you
yeah crap this is not good actually
[Music]
overcooked it but I shouldn't lose this
I should be fine
wait 93 I can actually play
I would then Rook D2
but then I have nights before that's
good
oh but I can't
feel bad this is really good
yeah
93 was a serious error
[Music]
and he's this move I also forgot about
that
using this last chance let's get active
let's get active
yeah but he takes here so accurate
might as well have just gone for the
ruling draw
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
to hold
yeah I forgot I had Queen G2 here
would have gone for this
but um
on second I mean 23 of course this
should be better but with such a king
how am I ever supposed to win the same
game
no this is not winnable
although maybe we need to
it kind of bummed I didn't see that
[Music]
but I don't think I would have won this
well now I start taking stuff
yeah it's only well it's 0.1.8
.5 that's not much at all
I defended very accurately though he was
winning in one move to be completely
Fair
all he had to do was play Queen F6 I
think and it's over
this is just winning on the spot because
I have to trade otherwise he wins up to
I saw this move and this is just Pawn up
night end game that should be winning
good game
should have tried to go G4 of course and
get him nervous but
I was nervous myself
okay let's try to win the last one
I mean I I don't really I'm not really
contending for first but with nine out
of ten I can do a pretty good job oh and
there's a lot of draws so farusha might
actually be the only one on eight and a
half out of ten
okay Dimitri is gonna play
for Russia for top spot and we're gonna
try to win the last one and get nine out
of 10 respectable score
here we go
here we go
okay Eric good good pairing in the last
round
and things
yeah I know this in H6 this is all I
know okay
I'm waiting okay let's be careful
because 95 Knight C4 is annoying
I know this is fine for black but
you don't really know how
actually I think this is fine
it goes Bishop C4 yeah I kind of like
saying that
okay let's get the pizza I'm allowing
him to play A5 but okay
he's allowing me to play five
yeah we should definitely play a five I
mean I don't wanna
maybe three
it's fine
it's totally fine in a castle
yeah maybe I'm slightly worse
I want to go Knight H5
[Music]
we haven't done this I've wanted this
move
all right
good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
nothing crazy here I'm still solid but I
can feel this crumbling
this is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it might have been um
before
no before
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
's disconnected there in the middle too
yeah
sounds like a tennis game
it was like a tennis game
all right thanks Eric Gigi got lucky
there
he totally outplayed me in the opening
um thank you for the sub Charles blue I
found when I found this idea G5 G4 I
knew I was gonna win because there was
just no way he stops it in time pressure
there was a couple of times I almost
lost on time
so I'm just happy happy at the good
internet
oh
now wait a second we're gonna type for
first whoa whoa whoa whoa there's a big
group with nine out of 11. farooza Drew
and my tie breaks are pretty damn good
now I'm very pessimistic because I know
my tyrex are going to be worse than most
other peoples because they always are
but maybe just once I can catch a tie
break break
maybe I can just for one sketch a tie
break break
yeah this is the current my tie breaks
are are the best right now
third okay we get third
and we get third by look at this look at
these tie breaks
missionic somehow has the best tie
breaks and then ditch and then I knocked
out for ruja
could have easily been first
um
if I think one other player had probably
won
but we'll take it
but I think I played really well I
didn't lose a single game nine out of
eleven eighth third place like 300 bucks
or whatever
um we'll take it
yeah could have easily been first but I
didn't really deserve first with 9 out
of 11 that would have been
underwhelming
yeah I've never seen this end ending
before in title Tuesday
tons of six people with nine out of 11.
I didn't win all my games I drew a
couple games there's a result that's not
when and not a draw
you're surprised it's that much for a
tournament with 60 GMS
um where you have to basically win all
of the games in order to get 250 bucks I
mean
I don't think I don't play the title
Tuesday for money
um I don't remember what the prize is
let me see
yeah Hikaru was absent to all the wolves
yeah
it's uh 300
350.
that's a big difference yeah Thousand
Seven fifty and 350. I don't remember if
the prizes are shared though I don't
think they are
yeah it's 1K for first so somehow
serrana sneaks in I don't understand how
he snuck in
and he lost a game really early
but somehow these tiebreaks always seem
to work in
in I don't know not in my favor I don't
know
but I could have easily been sixth like
Dimitri
so I guess my tie breaks were middling
yeah
it was a good it was a great tournament
I I started well at four out of four
what were the highlights the highlights
were
I mean I played a nice game in round
we played a nice game around in round
three where I won his piece like this
bishop Page Six
then I
I don't know what the tie breaks are
actually my nicest game I don't
understand why I can't click there we go
my nicest game was against Ibarra
I have no idea how the tie breaks work
so your guess is as good as mine all I
know is like whatever the tie breaks are
mine will not be the best so that I can
tell you straight away this was a nice
game
I mean normally if you don't lose a
single game your tie breaks are supposed
to be good but you know this system
doesn't seem to factor anything
significant into account I really don't
know the total score of your 10 opponent
so if one guy at in the last round had
one instead of losing I would have
gotten first that was the difference
yeah it is what it is there's just
nothing you can do to control that yeah
Knight C6 is a great move
yeah then I survived against Sully res I
was lost I got lucky this tournament I
mean I'd be jababa
I beat your baba in that it flagged
jababa then I won yeah then I made three
draws that was the critical part of the
tournament I made three draws two of
them were the white pieces that's that's
what I you can't accept if you want to
win title two so you can't you can't
just not challenge these guys with the
white pieces
my game with farusha was like probably
my worst of the tournament it was highly
lackluster
but then I
delivered in critical moments to save to
save the game
96 very nice move
and then finally the winner of the arc
was total barn burner
total Barn burn I need to look this
opening up I was definitely much worse
I was definitely much worse but then I
defended really well this bishop ba
Bishop A7 idea was really nice
well I I thought I wasn't veteran and I
was low on time
can you propose a plan there
I mean I found a great move Queen G3 and
it's winning
[Music]